[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 8 le débat l'économie
blinoise vettel à contretemps les
premiers chiffres du chômage de mai 18
signalent une augmentation de près de 1%
du nombre de chômeurs de catégorie a
dans le département soit une progression
de 2% sur un an et tendances divergentes
de celles enregistrées au niveau
régional qui elle demeure stable
des chiffres décevant regard de la bonne
croissance en 2017 et s'accompagne d'un
ralentissement économique et des trois
premiers mois de l'année ce qui nous
mène à cette question à qui on la
reprise économique et la baisse du
chômage dans les yvelines pour boucher
un début de réponse chaque oeil autour
de moi et roanne le gall conseiller
communautaire délégué à l'emploi de
saint quentin en yvelines
xavier aubry président du tribunal de
commerce de versailles mais également
pauline luciani par zadi directrice
territoriale délégués des yvelines à
pôle emploi bonsoir à vous tous et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
on va revenir notamment sur ces chiffres
du chômage qui sont tombés il ya
maintenant quelques semaines donc c'est
1% depuis le début de l'année mais
également 2 % de hausse sur un an ce que
même l'une des plus fortes augmentations
parmi eux au niveau régional comment
est-ce qu'on peut expliquer ce chiffre
est ce que ça vous étonne
alors oui on aurait souhaité
effectivement pouvoir poursuivre là
la régression en fait de la d2 nombre
d'inscrits en catégorie à
qu'on constate depuis depuis maintenant
un an
maintenant je tiens à rappeler que le
chômage le taux de chômage dans les
yvelines pour le coût continue de
baisser puisque on a un taux de chômage
de 6 26% à fin décembre 2010 est qu'il
est en baisse de 0 29% et que ça les
yvelines reste le département le moins
touché par le chômage
parce que c'est quand même un signe d'
alerte deux ans attachement lots de miss
un peu atone ou lesbienne peut-être
jetons marque ou alors on n'est pas moi
je ne suis pas je ne suis pas pessimiste
je pense que la situation de l'emploi
est vraiment particulièrement favorable
sur ce début 2018
et pour ça on s'appuie sur notre enquête
besoins de main d'oeuvre
l'édition 2018 qui pour le coup montre
que les yvelines enregistre la plus
forte progression dans les projets de
recrutement porté par les recruteurs on
a eu des retours exprimé par environ
7000 entreprises yvelinoise avait
ensuite entre les projets les faits il
ya quand même un gap qui notamment la
confiance dans l'avenir et justement au
niveau des entreprises ce qui allait
leur état de santé aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous avez justement d'accroissement
justement des entreprises en difficulté
au début de l'année pas depuis début de
l'année mais moi je j'aurai un autre
point de vue si je puis dire par rapport
à ces problématiques économiques des
yvelines et de l'emploi
je reçois régulièrement les statistiques
de l'urssaf qui donne une évolution au
niveau de l'île de france en particulier
de l'emploi
département par département et il se
trouve que les yvelines et le
département d'ile-de-france qui a
probablement eu sur 2017 alors j'ai
peut-être des chiffres un petit peu
anciens la progression la plus faible en
moyenne sur les deux français et de
mémoire 1,8 pour cent de progression de
l'emploi en 2017 mais simplement 0 4%
pour les yvelines alors je suis heureux
de constater qu'il ya des intentions
d'emploi d'augmentation de recrutement
et cetera sur le début de l'année 2018
certes le taux de chômage dans les
yvelines est relativement faible c'est
entendu mais le dynamisme même du
département ne me paraît pas aussi
perceptibles que dans d'autres
départements de l'île de france
donc moi c'est une version peut-être un
peu pessimiste que je formule et
concernant un simple sujet qui est celui
des ouvertures de procédures collectives
s'il ya des difficultés des entreprises
nous avons plutôt une stabilisation plus
qu'une régression constatée dans
d'autres départements d'accord quand
vous vous êtes plutôt mitigé vous êtes
plutôt positive et justement quel est
votre point de vue au niveau de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui est quand même en tout -
économique important alors cela et vous
avez raison de le dire c'est un poumon
économique très très important au sein
des yvelines et même de la région ile de
france il ya deux choses je t'assure le
mixte dé de la faire la synthèse
il faut nous avons des communes qui ont
un taux de chômage qui ont crû de 4% la
cale comme magny les hameaux comme
voisins le bretonneux
voilà et nous avons des communes qui ont
des taux de chômage qui sont presque qui
avoisine entre 25 et 30 pour 5 ans mais
quel est le dynamisme injuste alors je
finis juste par rapport à ça c'est que
on a des typologies de population qui
est dans les quartiers prioritaires
donc c'est quelque chose sur lequel on
doit on doit porter de la tension aussi
c'est à dire que on doit regarder être
très attentif à cet art pour pouvoir en
sortir mais en sortir avec des vraies
mesures
c'est à dire que pour vous en faites le
chômage proviennent des populations déjà
défavorisées jeudi soir alors j'ai dit
que quand vous faites une quand vous
posez vos questions et vous faites une
analyse sur l'ensemble du territoire
l on exclut pas c'est comme une ado
qu'elles en font partie donc évidemment
ce sont des taux qui impacte la moyenne
donc et on le sait et on doit faire
quelque chose
voilà j'ai pas que c'est la cause mais
il faut trouver une raison pour en
sortir
ça c'est une des pistes
lorsqu'on sait qu'il ya des entreprises
qui sont fortes demandes de l'influent
analyste notamment aujourd'hui sur cette
première pas sur les trois premiers mois
2010 8 est ce que vous justement vous
êtes plutôt confiant même si un recul de
chiffre d'affaires notamment d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises est ce que
vous vous êtes quand même confiant sur
l'avenir notamment du bassin économique
de saint quentin et clément moi je suis
confiant sur saint quentin en yvelines
et uzi et des yvelines parce que ya une
vraie dynamique économique j'ai
confiance en saint quentin parce que
nous sommes un vrai poumon économique il
ya 16 b l'entreprise évidemment que j'ai
confiance
je crains pas grand chose pour l'avenir
mais je mets dans vos chiffres
concernent a écouté mon en 2010
donc pour vous les chiffres du chômage
justement qui augmente dans les abîmes
ça vous concerne pas si ça me concerne
mais j en 2017
on a senti une légère relance économique
et qui qui s'essouffler très rapidement
voilà donc je sens qu'il ya quelque
chose qui est en train de repartir il
faut rassurer un certain nombre de
choses il faut rassurer le chef
d'entreprise voudrais rassurer
économiquement il faut accompagner comme
jeudi un certain nombre de jeunes c'est
quand même les moins de 25 ans les moins
de 25 ans et 25 pour cent le chômage
comme moi c'est ça qui ça c'est la
réalité
justement vous y venez à ce problème
notamment il ya un problème qui vient
lorsqu'on fait de reportage auprès des
chefs d'entreprise qui est le problème
notamment de la formation avec en
adéquation avec le besoin des
entreprises est ce que l'ajustement
concédé continuez vous allez faire
quelque chose justement pour pouvoir
avancer sur ce point là notamment au
niveau pôle emploi est ce que vous avez
choisi cc c'est quelque chose qui nous
qui pour le coup effectivement nous nous
préoccupe beaucoup parce qu'avec un taux
de chômage qui est plutôt faible avec
effectivement moi je rebondisse que sur
ce que dit erwan le gall c'est à dire
que on a un risque de deux d'éloignement
du marché du travail d'une partie des
inscrits à pôle emploi alors les
quartiers qu pv sont tus sont un sujet
il ya aussi la durée d'inscription à
pôle emploi puisque là on voit dans les
chiffres de mars que les ceux qui
sortent le plus rapidement à l'emploi ce
sont les
pardon les quartiers prioritaires
prioritaires de la ville on voit que les
gens les demandeurs d'emploi qui sortent
le plus rapidement à l'emploi
dernièrement ce sont ce les gens
inscrits depuis moins d'un an est en
revanche on a effectivement une
augmentation forte de l'ordre de 9% dans
les yvelines de la part des demandeurs
d'emploi inscrits depuis plus d'un an et
ça c'est un vrai problème parce que
c'est un sujet des d'équations des
compétences dans un marché du travail
qui avance à toute vitesse
l'adéquation des malades et des
compétences aux besoins en fait des
recruteurs si je reviens sur mon propos
de tout à l'heure sur la languette
besoins de main d'oeuvre on a un ratio
difficultés de recrutement exprimées par
les recruteurs qui est en forte hausse
ça veut dire que il ne trouve pas ou en
tout cas ils expriment des difficultés
sur les candidats qui de recherche et
donc face à ça on est avec nos
partenaires engagés sur des plans
ambitieux de développement des
compétences
donc on se fasse engagé avec le conseil
régional d'île de france sur le plan
d'investissement des compétences qui se
déploie on a aussi une approche intégrée
notamment sur le sujet du numérique
puisqu'il s'agit d'accompagner aussi des
entreprises en particulier tpe pme sur
l'inclusion numérique sur l'eure l'eure
le dépôt le déploiement d'outils
numériques dans l'eure dans leur
pratique dans la pratique
professionnelle et donc pour ça on va
aussi s'engager
on l'a dit on l'a déjà fait avec avec
saint quentin en yvelines qui est plutôt
précurseur sur ce domaine sur des
formations en direction de candidats
inscrits à pôle emploi avec des niveaux
de qualification plutôt infra bac sont
d'accord pour effectivement les former
et les mettre à l'emploi avec avec avec
ce type de compétences vous partage en
dehors notamment cet analyste
le manque de qualification peut freiner
le développement de certaines
entreprises
c'est évident je crois que le
département des yvelines est quand même
très différenciée comme nature d'emplois
dont il a besoin enfin dont les
entreprises installées dans les yvelines
ont besoin je crois que ça n'a rien
d'exceptionnel mais l'ouest du
département
les emplois sont des emplois qui sont
proches de l'agriculture d'une manière
générale ensuite mais quand on va venir
plus tôt vers le nord et l'est du
département on va trouver des
entreprises industrielles
on a toutes les entreprises qui assurent
sa salle a justement action davantage
impacté par ce problème de recrutement
exprime dans l'anc est le l'industrie
exprime particulièrement des difficultés
dans le recrutement
parce qu'effectivement c'est ainsi lors
c'est pas le secteur le plus
représentatif des yvelines s'est
principalement effectivement le domaine
le domaine des services mais l'industrie
reste quand même un gisement d'emplois
et là il ya des vrais besoins futurs des
vrais déficit de compétences parce que
ça signifiait justement de cette
entreprise ça n'arrive pas à trouver les
compétences et les talents dans les
gènes ce qui est un risque qui à part
tout simplement
alors c'est un oui alors potentiellement
en tout cas c'est un c'est un facteur
d'attractivité économique de tran
capacité de répondre à ces à ses besoins
là
nous on travaille de façon on cherche à
travailler de façon vraiment intégré
avec avec ses recruteurs alors on en a
sur sur le vo vous a l'air plutôt
dubitatif par un joueur dont je pense
qu' il n'y aura pas de délocalisation
n'a département à l'autre
il ya des entreprises qui sont installés
dans les yvelines depuis extrêmement
longtemps donc ya pas de risque en la
matière et le problème que nous évoquons
est un problème qui est générale en
france pour sa part 2010 à garoua que
les volants la volonté d'essayer
d'adapter la formation des salariés aux
besoins des entreprises est absolument
indispensable
donc là il ya un vrai effort de
formation professionnelle je crois que
les pouvoirs publics en ont parfaitement
pris conscience et c'est la seule façon
pour pouvoir trouver effectivement
notamment dans le domaine de l'industrie
les emplois et les compétences qui sont
nécessaires pour les entreprises afin
qu'elles se développent et tout notre
enjeu là dessus c'est effectivement de
travail avec les recruteurs pour
justement partir de leurs besoins et
aussi ouvrir leurs pratiques de
recrutement ça va être extrêmement
important encore une fois moi je suis
peut-être l'optimiste de la table mais
je considère à pôle emploi qui a un
risque fort sur les offres non pourvues
qui est un thème qui revient
régulièrement mais qui risquent
particulièrement de se poser en 2018
avec effectivement des diffusions de
postes qui sont en augmentation et qui
ne trouvent pas preneurs dont la
solution que nous on avance et on
travaille vraiment de façon de façon
transversale et on cherche à inclure
aussi nos partenaires dont fait partie
par exemple la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour travailler avec ses
recruteurs sur ce qu'on appelle nous
l'approchent compétences c'est-à-dire
sortir d'une idée de jeu recrute
quelqu'un qui a exercé le métier que je
recherche
et je pars des compétences qui sont
disponibles et j'avance là dessus nous
avons développé dans la promotion de
dispositif doit davantage axé sur la
capacité plutôt que sur les compétences
nos vêtements
donc là on fait avec sur le bassin on le
fait avec des entreprises comme
connaissons des ascensoristes qui manque
cruellement en fait de deux techniciens
donc là on monte des formations sur
mesure pour amener des publics qui n'ont
pas exercé dans ces métiers là pour
et là dessus on est en train de
travailler avec une société de levage la
sueur sur le bassin de saint quentin
pour effectivement travailler sur des
compétences qui leur manquent sur des
techniciens de maintenance
là aussi donc on peut aller chercher des
profils qui n'ont rien à voir non pas
d'expérience dans l'industrie corps la
question justement aujourd'hui les
différents leviers qu'on a encore dans
la main justement pour pouvoir booster
l'économie des yvelines parce que là il
semblerait qu'elle soit plutôt à la
traîne qu'il soit moins dynamique que
les autres départements aujourd'hui
quelles sont les solutions pour écouter
tout ce qui était dit là sont des outils
enfin les solutions
le chiffre d'affaires et les clients
seront là il ya une frilosité comme
année encore des personnes oui mais je
crois confiance et la frilosité des
changements sur un pont entre la
frilosité des allées nationale est
délocalisée enfin pour rebondir enfin la
problématique des yvelines de patrouille
la manoeuvre je trouvais la même
difficulté dans l'essonne en eure et
loir dans le finistère dans les roues ça
je vous rassure ans après c'est parce
que on est un bastion beaucoup plus fort
donc on nous regarde beaucoup plus à la
loupe
on est attentif moi je crois que sur le
département et le conseil départemental
fait beaucoup de choses aussi passe donc
pour l'insertion fait beaucoup de choses
aussi sur l'économie en tant que tel et
regarder très attentif à l'effet que je
shoote c'est l'agglomération va pas
relancer les investissements justement
pour vous donner de l'argent frères
encore et encore mais c'était eux je
suis désolé mais tout ce que l'on fait
auprès des centres d des entreprises
tout ce que les accompagnements qu'une
fois auprès des entreprises j'étais
encore il n'ya pas plus tard qu une demi
heure avec les initiatives ski il ya
quand même plus d'un million de porter
en projet pour des créateurs
d'entreprise évidemment quel
accompagnement évidemment on est
attentif à roro réseau associatif qui
porte et les grands comptes et les pme
et tpe il ya notamment un problème
récurrent notamment pour les entreprises
qui travaille notamment avec les
collectivités territoriales c'est le
délai de paiement c'est à dire qu'il ya
toujours justement entre l'offre lorsque
ces signes et lorsqu'ils reçoivent de
l'argent un délai très très long qui a
invité autour de la table des députés et
puis des sénateurs qui ont re la main
pour légiférer sur les lois moi je pense
qu'ici on n'est pas voir si ce n'est pas
la responsabilité des municipalités ou
des agglomérations du département les
appels d'offres il ya un délit en tant
que tel intelligent qui logiquement
oui mais pas les diktats payer c'est la
règle mois de 30 à 45 jours donc
après ça c'est celle à voir donc
c'est il y a je sais pas je pense que
vous avez les mêmes problématiques en be
to be les problèmes et les paiement
entre entreprises il ya aussi des délais
des fois regardez-le incompressibles et
puis des fois il ya des larves à
généraliser
disons au plan macroéconomique la
croissance des entreprises en france
fait par rapport aux autres entreprises
en termes de trésorerie fier que ce sont
les entreprises qui financent les autres
et laurie les autres entreprises pardon
à la différence d'autres pays où on a
des entreprises qui sont beaucoup plus
capitalisées et dans ces conditions le
délais de paiement entre fournisseurs et
clients est beaucoup plus court alors
qu'en france on joue là dessus pour
effectivement faire un passage difficile
de trésorerie on attend effectivement au
dernier moment pour pouvoir régler son
fournisseur c'est donc disons un état
d'esprit malheureusement des entreprises
françaises et de ce fait effectivement
on a parfois effectivement des
difficultés pour les voir se développer
l on pense qu'on va parler peut-être un
peu création d'entreprise elle manque de
capitaux et de ce fait elles sont
incapables de faire face par exemple à
une augmentation de leur activité
parce qu'elles n'ont pas le fond de
roulement suffisant pour pouvoir se
développer et cette problématique du
financement des entreprises restent
prégnants
depuis des années des années je l'avais
même dire pour depuis les décennies et
ceux ci restent non solutionner malgré
tous les efforts qui sont faits à tous
les niveaux que ce soit au niveau des
communes des communautés d'agglomération
au niveau du département au niveau de la
région
au niveau de l'état et ceux ci ça du mal
à sortir des habitudes par lequel c'est
l'entreprise qui finance une autre
entreprise ce qui n'est pas logique
juste pour rebondir comme sur saint
quentin permettez moi de dire deux ou
trois choses mais on fait les haies mais
rapidement on fait sky business day
c'est à dire que pendant toute une
journée il ya du bit lit on a mis en
place aussi l'événementiel pour le
tourisme d'affaires
et puis on fait là sur la d
entrepreneurs
trois mois d'autres agglo qui chutent
pas autant les entreprises que nous moi
je suis preneur
en tout cas s'il ya d'autres modèles on
les prend aussi on fait très attention
de l'entreprise et on les porte et on a
des indicateurs aussi elles sont plutôt
en bonne santé
après c'est là où enfin ce qu'il y avait
dans notre mission c'est vrai que le
problématique de la main d'oeuvre du bac
moins deux ou trois au bac +5 pc c'est
un vrai souci et au delà de la formation
et une culture d'entreprise
il va falloir réapprendre à l'école mais
là c'est urgent ça devient très très
urgent mais dès la maternelle je n'avais
pas de le dire mais c'est oui c'est dès
maintenant qu'il va falloir apprendre
les codes - entre présent de deux
missions locales je croise des jeunes
je vois je vais différents forums je
veux partager beaucoup de choses il ya
preuve de motivation bien propres de
code
voilà et la société est en train de
changer quelqu'un par exemple et bien
les codes de l'entreprise c'est se dire
que d'arriver en retard ne pas faire
attention à ses collègues ce n'est pas
grave parce que toi sont je suis seul
dans ce bateau et je fais ce que je veux
sauf que de faire ce que
de faire comme bon je souhaite je met en
porte-à-faux
mes collègues et l'entreprise voilà ça
ce sont des codes qu'il faut comprendre
que ce sont vraiment des changements en
profondeur
oui on vous me voir opposer mais ce soit
lui dit que pour le tout petit mais que
derrière ça devienne quelque chose de
systématique 1 et je trouve que là on a
le voile on le paye vraiment pas ce que
je vois qu'ils sont du savoir-être
l es l et nous on partage le le la
préoccupation parce que c'est quelque
chose que nous remonte les recruteurs
c'est à dire que on parle de la
compétence liée au savoir-faire ou au
savoir au niveau de diplôme etc
mais le
les qualités relationnelles et voilà ce
qu'on appelle le savoir-être devient
quelque chose d'incontournable en
particulier lorsqu'on va sur des
transitions professionnelles
donc on a des recruteurs moi je pense a
accueilli gagnent je pense à grandvision
etc qui acceptent de faire le pari de
dire on va pas recruter des vendeurs en
optique on va on accepte de les former
par contre là où on va être
effectivement extrêmement attentif c'est
sur le savoir-être sur effectivement
l'enthousiaste la capacité à travailler
en équipe
ce que vous disiez la ponctualité qui
voit là semble être une vieille notion
mais qui reste complètement d'actualité
et donc nous on va même jusqu'à on va
travailler en fait sur des sur des
prestations pour effectivement
remobiliser certains certains candidats
certains demandeurs d'emploi sur c'est
quoi un bon savoir être en entreprise
accord donc effectivement c'est pas un
petit c'est pas un petit sujet à
l'ancienne qu'est ce qu'il est possible
de faire notamment pour pouvoir
rebooster l'économie des entreprises les
mettre à flot est ce qu'il ya d'autres
solutions justement pour ça notamment
peut-être le conseil aux entreprises qui
peut-être tard d'autres os à venir
a demandé mme nada alors ça dépend le
stade de développement l'entreprise l'on
comprenne entreprises qui démarrent une
entreprise qui est mature qui va bien
une entreprise qui commence à rencontrer
des difficultés pour venir en aide si je
reprends le premier cas il faut que le
chef d'entreprise qui démarre il est un
vrai projet d'accord parce que notamment
ce quelque chose que des entrepreneurs
le soft a beaucoup c'est que l'être
humain de commerce s'est pas uniquement
pour acter la mort d'une entreprise mais
ceux-ci du conseil du soutien s'agit pas
de dire que le construit bien le
commerce rangs des conseils ou donne des
conseils aux chefs d'entreprise
il est là pour les alerter lorsqu
effectivement ils rencontrent des
difficultés
le tribunal comme s il est là pour
accueillir les entreprises qui justement
sentent qu'elles ont des difficultés et
que une chose absolument indispensable
c'est de ne pas tarder a effectivement
voir la vérité de la situation
d'entreprise le chef d'entreprise qui
tarde le chef d'entreprise qui joue un
peu l'autruche qui se dit bah je vais
avoir une commande
mon client va me payer bientôt mais tout
ceci ne donne pas lieu à une véritable
action de sa part eh bien il s'enfonce
petit à petit dans la difficulté et plus
il retardera une espèce de prise de
conscience plus lui sera difficile de
sortir de la situation dans laquelle il
est et plus il sera difficile pour le
tribunal de commerce de véritablement
l'aîné donc si j'ai un message à passer
vis-à-vis des chefs d'entreprise qu'il
démarre qu'ils soient déjà en pleine
activité
s'il commence à sentir que leur
trésorerie ce temps eh bien il est
absolument nécessaire de regarder les
choses en face d'anticiper ne pas avoir
peur de venir au tribunal de commerce on
n'est pas là pour condamner les
entreprises si on condamne beaucoup
d'entreprises à la liquidation parfois
immédiate c'est que le chef d'entreprise
a pris conscience de ces difficultés
beaucoup trop tardivement et qu'il n'est
pas venu pour essayer d'utiliser les
outils qui sont à la disposition du
tribunal de commerce pour l'aider
d'accord temps c'est surtout un
changement de mentalité
que vous tous nous demander autour de sa
table pour pouvoir justement permettre
de booster l'économie a vraiment aucune
autre mesure concrète tour de table pour
finir et plein d'autres mesures moi je
sais les conclusions je vais dire
simplement que nous avons besoin des
chefs d'entreprise l'économie se fait
avec les entreprises
il ne faut jamais l'oublier jamais
jamais jamais ce qui fait vivre une
nation les entreprises il faut faire
attention à eux
je vous rejoins monsieur certain moment
il faut la solitude du chef d'entreprise
la prise de décision c'est compliqué
donc c'est peut-être aussi avoir notre
système pour un cran pour un grande
alerte avant d'arriver à une solution
qui soit malheureusement irrémédiable
voilà mais je reste très positive jeu
des entreprises vont bien
nous on a un job à accomplir c'est par
rapport à l'employabilité à répondre à
leurs besoins
répondra aussi un certain nombre de
besoins
là je parle sur l'agglo
et avoir des réponses claires et
précises mais je crois que depuis pas
mal d'années on y répond et je crois
qu'on a pris des grands virages donc je
suis assez confiant pour l'avenir
après une relance économique ce sera une
relance national tout va pas être porté
sur le poumon économique de 2,50 en
libye pour relancer l'europe à un moment
il faut être aussi regarder vous voyez
il a vu ce dernier stats au niveau de la
pauvreté entre l'allemagne et la france
tu en train de décrier l'allemagne on
est le double par rapport à on est le
double par rapport à l'allemagne
donc ça sera l'objet peut-être une
future émission hockey à pôle emploi et
la direction territoriale des yvelines
on croit fermement que le défi yvelinois
dès maintenant c'est effectivement de
travailler avec les candidats d'une part
et les recruteurs d'autre part pour pour
travailler sur l'adéquation des
compétences pour permettre de pourvoir
compétences quelles qu'elles soient
quelle qu'elle soit pour permettre de
pourvoir pour voir de façon
satisfaisante les postes qui vont être
proposées katia maddens films concerts
notre email de commerce malheureusement
on voit plutôt les entreprises qui ont
des difficultés des entreprises qui vont
bien on ne les voit pas et c'est tant
mieux
est ce que je souhaiterais c'est que on
veut porter le développement de
l'entreprise regret des entreprises
on pense qu'effectivement comme vous le
dites c'est là où il ya la création de
richesses mais il faut pas oublier que à
la création ou même dans la vie de
l'entreprise c'est bien la voir de très
beaux projets pour la développer mais il
faut un minimum de compétences pour la
gérer c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
toujours connus ou suffisamment
développé le ce sera le mot de la fin
merci à vous tous d'avoir accepté cette
invitation quant à vous je vous invite à
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet passent une agréable soirée il
ya la semaine prochaine
[Musique]